[Music]
hey what is up guys I'm Kim PhD here and
this is gonna be a quick video on
something just because it's been covered
in depth by a lot of people already if
you're subscribed to anyone else Tech on
YouTube you've probably already seen
this or if you're not subscribed to any
other tech channels on YouTube maybe
this is the first time you're seeing
this but this is the iPhone 6 dummy body
so a lot of people have been getting
their hands on this courtesy of Sony
Dickson who has had some notoriously
great Apple leaks in the past I'll leave
his Twitter link down below if you want
to check that the rest of the stuff he
shared but this is supposed to be our
first look at the body shape and size of
the iPhone 6 but what it really is is
the the dummy phone that a lot of the
case manufacturers will use to create
and start producing their iPhone 6 cases
before the phone has actually been
announced so this is basically made up
of all your rumors all of your
speculation all of the things we know
about the parts of the next iPhone to
give a general idea of the shape and
size that this next phone will be so I'm
gonna make this quick since it's been
covered already like I said but there
are three main characteristics that
you're gonna want to know about this
before the next iPhone comes out because
they're pretty much set in stone at this
point and that is the rounded edges the
much bigger display and slightly bigger
bezels also and the extreme thinness of
this new phone so for the rounded edges
this is just something about the design
I've noticed since I've had it it's a
departure from all the iPhones we've had
since the iPhone 4 the one right before
at the iPhone 3GS was when it was last
curved now I'm not the first to say it
but this new dummy really reminds me of
the HTC One m8 at a glance and I've
talked a lot about how the m8 feels in
the hand thanks to its metal body and
the roundness in the full review so it's
definitely not going to be quite as
slippery as the m8 mostly because it's
not quite as big but that brings us to
our next point which is the size of this
iPhone like I said this is a big iPhone
the biggest phone Apple will ever make
this dummy sports a 4.7 inch display and
there are a whole ton more rumors that
support this and a 1704 by 960
resolution here it is next to the iPhone
5s which has a 4-inch display and you
can see not only is it taller but it's a
bit wider too it's definitely in much
bigger phone than Apple as
were made I'm actually finding the
bezels seem to be kind of big compared
to a lot of other phones out now it
makes it look a little ugly but even the
other iPhones have smaller bezels than
this the Moto X is a pretty popular
Android phone this also has a 4.7 inch
display but you can see it's much
smaller than the iPhone 6 dummy and not
nearly as tall of course that doesn't
need to make room on the front for a
home button but I feel like the iPhone
has some pretty big bezels for the
display you're getting but of course
finally where this phone is definitely
not big is the thickness Department
we've seen this before the iPhone 6 is
going to be a very thin phone we're
talking like six millimeters thin here
in a metal unibody case which is very
impressive and Apple's never really had
problems with battery life on the iPhone
I mean it's not the greatest but seeing
a new iPhone that's even thinner than
the current iPhone
konna gets me questioning how big of a
battery they can fit in here but you
know I guess if the iPhone is a lot
taller maybe they'll have enough space
to fit the same sized battery who knows
I just I always think about battery life
when I see a phone as thin as this but
as you can see here if we check out one
of these pre-production iPhone 6 cases
here which has the interior measurement
of just 6 millimeters we can put the
iPhone 6 dummy in it and of course if
it's just perfectly all the cutouts and
all the speakers and the Lightning port
and the headphone jack and the volume
and mute switch they're all still there
and it's the same thinness now as the
iPod Touch which is incredibly
impressive and I don't really see any
other phones out there that are quite as
well built and only 6 millimeters thick
so it's really impressive and has me
pretty curious but that's about it as
far as the aesthetic stuff there also of
course some other minor things which I
guess are major when it comes to the
iPhone where the power button relocation
it is now on the side of the phone which
makes sense because it's a bigger phone
and it would be harder to reach the top
so it makes sense to put that power
button in an easy to reach spot but
other than that nothing else really all
that exciting about the new iPhone 6
dummy Apple could of course surprise us
and have some other crazy new features
or hardware stuff but this is about as
good a look as we're gonna get the
iPhone 6 right now what I find most
interesting is actually the way people
react to it so I'm gonna I'm gonna jump
this right back at you guys
would you buy a 4.7 inch display iPhone
would you buy
big iPhone like this I know the the back
markings might not be finalized and this
might not be the exact final look of the
design but it tends to look a lot better
when it's an actual working phone and
the thing is on I'm also gonna leave a
link to your average consumers video
where he actually went out and showed
people the iPhone 6 dummy and asked hey
would you buy this if this was the next
iPhone and he got some pretty
interesting answers so I'll leave that
link right below like button check out
that video and other than that that's
about it so thanks for watching this
quick video talk to you guys in the next
one peace
[Music]